I'm at her parents house in an extra
bedroom and I'm the guy that she met
from the internet that she quit her job
for who just lost everything and I had a
thousand dollars left and it was
December of 2016. and I was like I I
think you should leave me
um I I think I am a sinking ship right
now and
I would respect you like we're cool if
you want to walk away I would walk away
from you right now she pulled my chin
towards her and she was like
I would sleep with you under a bridge if
it came to that
she has brought out the absolute best in
me like in in just about every way like
didn't think we're gonna go here
um
she just She Believes In Me
and I think that's what most guys want
truly
at least for me that's what I wanted
or needed